[Music]
the decision to sell my home and move
into an apartment after 34 years was met
with mixed emotions from friends and
relatives but it's the best thing i ever
did for myself how can we maintain peace
when loved ones question our beliefs
i think that the last part of that
question is really the question i wanted
to get to here because that is the
question behind the question right yes
i'm making one decision
it's frustrating my friends
quite often because they think what oh
if he does something different that
might that must be a judgment on my
beliefs my
my worldview
a judgment on my actions if you don't
act in accordance with my actions
and you certainly stumbled into that a
bunch of times you know throughout
throughout this book even
there's
there's kind of two aspects of that that
that i
would like to look at a little bit
because one aspect is
that sometimes us growing and doing what
we need to do is going to cost
relationships and is going to cost
um
you know
approval
some people aren't going to approve
right and
that's when we have to weigh like how
important is
this
you know
maybe maybe you we have a conversation
about the aliens and i'm like that seems
true yeah do how important is that that
i need to broadcast that i'm going to
change my whole podcast about that now
i'm going to tell all my family about
person now it's becoming an identity
thing how important
are the like
are there parts of my growth and
evolution that that can just be for me
and i don't have to get other people on
board with it yeah
um so there's that aspect of it but
there's another aspect that
i've been discovering more and more
which is that the thing that we're
afraid of being rejected or shamed or
heretical and
to your world
the less shame that i carry about that
myself uh the less like problem i have
with it
it doesn't last long for the other
person i found usually
it's like it kind of reminds me i have
this friend uh
who
was going through a really hard time a
few years ago and she's a celebrity
and she was going through kind of a
she was just totally offline just
totally
in her own world because she was going
through all this stuff
and she just found out this year that
she was kind of cancelled
back then there was like some
internet she had said something that was
like
people were all mad and
she didn't know oh she came out as a
juices didn't she
but she didn't know till now
yeah and it didn't affect anything right
she didn't resp she didn't react
she wasn't like oh this but this is what
i'm defending my position she didn't get
in a fight and it didn't affect she just
like i got canceled and i never knew
yes and there's something about that
energy that i think like
i can't believe you're selling your
house in your apartment you're like yeah
isn't it wild
and if you don't if you don't
own the [ __ ] if you don't carry the
shame yourself it's like they don't have
anything to lock onto sometimes it's
like it's just kind of you become a
smooth surface and they're like clawing
at it and just like ah
yeah
i don't think that's a good idea and
then it's done yeah
do you want to go get some coffee or you
know it's just like all right we're
gonna get coffee now if you don't let
them
if it doesn't come from you there's no
resonance there's no
sticking point
yeah we had uh porn star lisa ann on the
podcast
and uh it was the week after we had
erwin mcmanus on the podcast
and um they actually talked about a lot
of similar things and you're sort of the
you're the confluence of the two um
the best
you're like
what was her name lisa
what was her name
yeah i don't know i've never seen it
either
anyway
she uh
there was a question that came up from
an audience member and they said you
know it was they're asking about dealing
with shame and she goes well i don't
have to deal with my shame the biggest
thing is i have to deal with a lot of
other people
the shame they try to hurl on to me
based on their own judgments yeah
expectations beliefs world views
opinions
yeah it's almost like they look at
donna here and they're like
donna's happy with what she did but i
can never do that and if i
if if i could do that then i like they
lose their identity that they're wrapped
up in so then they hurled their shame
adana to be like you're crazy for doing
this because i think it's crazy if i
ever did that
yeah it's uh yeah it's easier said than
done to let go of shame but yeah but uh
but yeah especially maybe it's a little
bit easier when donna realizes
that it's not the same chance to let go
of as much as when someone hurls their
shame in her she doesn't have to catch
it yeah
and
it plays out in ways practically where
it's like
if i feel shame that their i take that
shame on or i've let that projected
shame cause my shame to project back at
them then i'm going
i keep wanting to bring it up and talk
about it and get them to agree and like
i keep talking to my dad about
he's got to see things my way all right
and
and sometimes there's a shame fuel under
that because it's like i'm not okay
having any dissonance or disagreement so
we
and i need you to see me as being okay
otherwise i don't feel okay but if i
just feel okay and i'm like yeah i
understand that this isn't a bizarre
thing to do in your perspective
thank you for your input yeah right but
it's important to me yeah and you just
left it there
who in the world is going to keep coming
back
if they do eventually then they're
insulting or attacking you then you can
create some distance
right but it sounds like right now it's
it's not about that it's just
the need to appease them to
get their veneration or validation
is keeping you stuck in some old belief
that is no longer serving you
and sorry one more thing is like we
think that the lie of that
that's built into that is that we think
that by keeping that shame by like
protecting
that that by not by avoiding doing the
thing um that we want to do
that will that will keep away the shame
but it's actually the thing that's
creating the shame yes
we're actually creating the shame by
trying to avoid it did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free